alright guys super excited to have Nolan
here welcome sir happy to be here
awesome we got a lot to cover so let's
jump right in what is your background so
trained as a lawyer but didn't really
practiced it a bit of time in Japan I
was actually there for when the white
paper was written and you can take the
bar now I didn't actually I got the
first job out of college basically you
know I graduated right into the meltdown
so that was a real fun time and but I
got lucky I got this gig on a deal in
Japan and went there for a few months
and then when I came back to Canada I'm
Canadian when I came back we have an
oversized influence in this industry so
I understand why everyone's against it
so when I came back to Canada I became a
long form long study researcher for the
Senate Banking Committee in Canada and
we looked into first the meltdown so we
brought in central bankers and why
Canada was insulated from it but really
you know tackling macroeconomic issues
as they related to banking law all right
before we go on hold on tell me more
about this this investigation or
research that you guys did into the
meltdown well I mean it was basically it
was bit Canada centric I'll say it was
why were we insulated so Canada as a
federation is divided almost the same as
America entirely inspired by the
American distribution of federalism to
the states and and federal government
except from one major difference banking
law is all federal done on purpose
because we're having trouble financing
the railway projects and canals and and
etc so it was really looking at why our
banking law was different why we
insulated you know the conservatism we
were known for in banking in the 90s and
early 2000s ended up being in our
advantage
we weren't mortgaged obviously we didn't
have subprime it was you know mortgage
insurance was much more important aspect
of our economy but then just looking at
the contagion as well how it how it all
came about and and then why Canada was
successful you saw a buying spree of
Canadian banks immediately after I mean
it's TD Bank is all over in New York
City now and
you see these Canadian brand names that
did quite well acquiring distressed
American banks but we definitely did
look at the Basel Accords and and
everything else that went on with with
the reaction to the meltdown and we
definitely got into you know the
decisions central bankers made so we had
the central bankers we had mark Carney
in to testify several times Carney of
course was the governor of the Canadian
bank before he went to England and at
that time you know he had a lot of
interesting things to say and was not
pulling any punches so everyone was sort
of happy to finally criticize some of
the policies that central bankers were
offering and under so we kind of
contained that all into a narrative and
and it was focused on Canada for sure
but you know global global moves and
global changes and why that all happened
did you guys like [ __ ] on the Americans
when you're doing it I don't think it
was we weren't really after anyone in
particular it was I think the Deutsche
Bank guys got the worst of it it was the
people who jumped in feet-first I don't
think it was it didn't really focus on
that part yeah the reaction was a part
of it like how much quantitative easing
was induced by that was an issue we
didn't have to do it in Canada so we
were definitely looking at what are the
effects of this quantitative easing
being um you know it's not just Japan
and Europe anymore it was coming
everywhere
so what does that mean for us so that
was kind of how we looked at it a year
after that when Mountain was done we did
one on money laundering and terrorism
finance so basically the FinCEN regime
in America but yeah that we came down to
Washington and met the FinCEN folks and
had some insight but that's where I
learned about Bitcoin it was just in one
of these passing conversations where
someone said look we have this regime to
you know catch people if they're using
the ten thousand dollar transactions and
this and that
and one you know it was a
I either from RCMP or FBI or I'm not
sure who they said well and way do you
get a load of this this Bitcoin thing
like it's here
Oh people were using it they had known
about it and we're mentioning that the
things they were talking about might
even be their solutions might even be
obsolete in the short term was kind of
the lead-in because this is coming down
yeah and they meant it like as a joke
you know I this Bitcoin thing and I said
Bitcoin what is this and and so I
started learning and in 2013 when it
came time for the sort of selection of a
new year-long study I was right in there
to push Bitcoin and we got it they gave
us a really yeah they gave us a nice
large budget and and we got to fly
everyone in and we brought ondrea's
Antonopoulos we brought all kinds of
luminaries I happen to be living in
Toronto for most at that time too so you
know I would go up when the committee
was in session to Ottawa or capital but
I was in I was in Toronto a lot not far
from decentral I was gonna say there's a
ton of stuff going on at the time yeah I
was with I was there I would go all the
time and get sort of advice from these
people because I was still trying to
figure stuff out I'd come at it from law
and sort of macroeconomic policy I
didn't really know much about
cryptography or anything like this so I
had a ton of questions and and although
I found it really you know interesting
at first and and and knew how to attack
it from from tackle it from what I knew
I knew there was so much I didn't know
yep so I became sort of a student of
cryptography at that time and realized
that that was the most important thing
for me anyway to learn about so I
started reading all the text books and
and major advancements in cryptography
and and and just learning the history of
what it was so I developed a bit of a
thesis around a brown what was going on
at the time and we actually did a really
neat thing with a study block 3,600
whatever we actually hashed it into
bitcoins blockchain as we tabled in
Parliament with the lines Senate Banking
Committee believes satoshis invention
deserves a light regulatory touch so you
can see that any time and we actually
got you know we drafted all of the
recommendations which were like you know
leave them alone this is a really
empowering technology don't regulate we
met with the New York superintendent at
the time
but mas Qian told him me was way too far
ahead and being entrepreneurial even
with with regulations we said from our
you know view this is not this is really
premature to this sort of this is all
the bit lights and stuff there's all the
bit license stuff because it was the
2014 22 2015 time and you know we met
the Australian Senate Banking Committee
they came up and visited us for for
guidance and advice and what we were
doing and and from there the moment that
study was done I said what am i think
they asked me to study pensions or
something next and I said well that's
not gonna happen that don't worry we all
know they say exactly I was only getting
worse the virus was was was in me I had
been infected and there was no doing
anything else obviously so I started
going on my own a little bit doing some
consultations and and working with a bit
of those the Toronto set at the time and
then Coyne desk was bought and was moved
to America and it started in in London
and a lot of people don't know that yeah
it started in London and I mean they had
they had journalists in America but they
had started in London and so they were
bought in 2015 and when they moved to
America I was doing it remotely but
doing some more long-form research and
then I had a kind of a hack at the time
where I would go to not Bitcoin
conferences around the world so I would
never go to a normal Bitcoin conference
but I would go to the incumbent
industries which might be disrupted by
the technology so I would go to supply
chain conferences and insurance
conferences and I would do sort of
one-on-ones and then I would stay in
that city for a few weeks and and get
consulting jobs where I was just sort of
you know walking people through and then
part of the lesson was for them to pay
me in Bitcoin at the end that was sort
of a major part of what we were doing so
I did that in Europe and I did that in
Asia and
and I did that for a little while but
then a lot of travel and I could see in
2017 the market was changing and and you
know what I was doing for 101 and
introductions and and sort of evangelism
was going to be a little different and I
wanted to do something a little
different so you know coined as folks
said why don't you come to New York City
run our research department and and you
can live here and and change your you
know career of it and and and do
something a little more focused and so
that's what I did I came in 2017 right
in time for the crazy bull run so to say
2017 feels like just yesterday was
pumping stuff on the Internet yeah
everything was the hundred xing you got
it and it was really neat to come to New
York City you know New York City is a
tough town of course and you can come
here and only to outsiders but but it
can grind people right to the ground and
and what was neat was to come into this
amazing market where the knowledge that
I had was really useful and valuable to
a lot of people so I walked into the
city and it was just a fun time I got to
do a lot of you know interesting
meetings with interesting people and and
so I haven't looked back it's been a
great time and I love the city and
enjoyed it awesome what exactly do you
do as the head of research like I feel
coinbase has this unique spot in the
market where they're owned by one of the
most active investors right they
obviously have kind of sister companies
but there's also this kind of Chinese
firewall is my understanding with the
media and some of that but then also you
guys know all the players you know all
the the projects and companies and so
just really integral you know part or
centerpiece to its most the industry so
yeah I'll give you a lot of resources
it's amazing actually that that's sort
of what I've always really appreciated
it is to be at the center of the whole
industry and to have a real bird's-eye
view a real bird's-eye view so the the
firewall is real I mean our journalists
have zero contact in there I mean not
even Christmas parties type of thing I
think maybe Christmas party but that's
about it
right they don't wait wait coin desk
shares the Christmas party with Michael
Moore oh I think they've been invited
but I mean it but it but it's not a joke
it is very
serious internally I mean they really
really police it there's just no Condit
because we have to write about these
people too and in order for us to do
that we've got to be critical so I'm not
on the editorial side of the company so
I don't make those decisions but it is
you know it's it's it's unfortunate
there is a perception I'm not gonna try
and change it here today but if you saw
internally the the lengths to which
editorial went to to make sure that
isn't a reality it would surprise a lot
of people I promise you somebody's gonna
tweet at us about the Christmas party
all right but but even that is like
maybe they can go so as you're kind of
in the day job right there there's a
couple of different aspects of what you
guys have done there's what I would
consider like more traditional research
right then you guys have built this this
new product that we talked about maybe
just start at like a really high level
what is kind of the goal or the mandate
right is it to educate internally
educate externally visit to create
content and drive views kind of what
what do you view as hey here's why
here's why we exist so educate and
inform is a major part of it but I'd say
to put this in the larger historical
narrative we're not trying to just say
this person made some money and they did
well and this company didn't do well I
mean there's a larger narrative here and
I guess I would I break it down to you
know what what I learned in cryptography
own take but but I think is is sort of
infused and in line with the way the
company would see it you know
cryptography started as a tool that only
state actors used it was for war after
World War two we saw that was really the
case because it was made illegal for any
other person to get involved with
cryptography because they realize what
the powers were with World War two and
the Turing machine and and enigma and
everything they did so when they when
they stopped all there was no education
you couldn't go to university for this
stuff it was it was just stopped the
first private sector innovations happen
in the 1970s when public key
cryptography was invented by Whitfield
Diffie who was one of our keynotes last
year at consensus
so you know it went from the state actor
to companies that did cryptography for
you if you told them your dog's name and
your mother's maiden name and all this
crazy stuff yeah and then they traded
that information because you were too
stupid to run your you know to satisfy
your cryptographic needs Bitcoin of
course was the original and most widely
distributed example of public key
cryptography put in the hands of the
individual so the meta-narrative for us
is to really show people that they are
being empowered by this new technology
that cryptography that the power of
using a cryptographic key to express
consent is really what we're talking
about that individuals can now do this
that it that it is taken away lots of
discretion from other people that we've
trusted until now to do these things and
put them in the hands of individuals so
the narrative that we're trying to tell
is much larger and and we're really
anchored in telling the biggest story
here that that people can use
historically to look back on what
happened if people are drastically under
estimating how much work right both
regulatory technology socially have gone
into pre 2008-2009 any of this being
possible right and that's a I think
applicable not only in just kind of
electronic cash if you know right in all
the different variations that people
tried over the last thirty years or so
cryptography is obviously a whole nother
one and I remember and I've talked to us
before but Zucco told me one time he
said look you know this encryption and
all stuff used to be fought by the
government they say you cannot do this
you cannot do this and you know what are
you hiding why do you need encryption
right and and it finally came to a head
and obviously there was much a hearings
and things like that but today it's best
practice yeah right and so this world
where you know you would never imagine
using a product where certain
communication wasn't encrypted etc
that's not the normal statement and you
see it even today I mean this was done
inadvertently but that gdpr people are
always going on about right there our
GDP are this and GDP are that they put
an exclusion in GDP our they didn't mean
to put an exclusion that helped us as an
industry but they did say privacy by
design which is the best practice if you
if the users keep their keys with them
it is privacy by design and therefore
exempt from
er yeah well that's what we're doing
here we're trying to build a system
where everyone can use these
cryptographic keys with their person to
express consent I think most Americans
the only thing they know about gdpr is
that it made a bunch of emails got sent
reauthorized for websites but other than
that most people are completely lost it
was hilarious that the the the tool that
was designed to keep us from getting
spam and you know became the greatest
spam and do you ever fly two weeks it
was like every day you get multiple
emails every day every day but the good
news is a real robust decentralized
public chain theoretically is a hundred
percent exempt from this law yep
and so you can start to see the
implications of what that means you know
you look at cyber insurance right now
it's a terrible product I mean just the
worst and they don't really get much
they get a little bit of value if a
network goes down the insurance will pay
it doesn't really help reputationally
you can start to imagine a day where
cyber insurance premiums are lowered if
a company chooses one of our platforms
you know it's like putting a sprinkler
system into a you know your if you do it
then your premiums come down it's a
better practice so you don't need to
regulate that people do it this way but
don't do it because they'll save money
and that's part of what we're hoping to
see happen here and so that's a major
part of what's driving it got it and so
let's talk about you know obviously you
guys have this really big vision of
where do we come from what work did it
take and where we are today and even
into hey here's where we think the
world's going in the future and one
thing you guys recently created is this
crypto economic Explorer yeah so maybe
tell us a little bit about what that is
and kind of why you guys created that so
I'd say that with the you know 2017 the
major story the major takeaway in the
end is that people had gone over that
psychological hump and they've now
accepted something digital as property
right that that was one of the big
things that had to happen people would
say a lot of some big coins not real I
don't trust it before that but now all
the sudden that people started to see
well it's limited supply it is property
I started a trust that that they had
actually had a piece of natively digital
property it sort of changed people's
minds about what it meant and that was
really important but what we saw was one
of the important pillars of the industry
Wall Street and
and speculation being the only real use
case that we've actually been able to
establish as a solid thing you know that
happened but everyone started organizing
their analysis of the industry around
Wall Street metrics and around how Wall
Street's thought we definitely recognize
the importance of Wall Street and when I
said Wall Street I mean you know sort of
the idea of Wall Street yes could be
anyone interested in trading and
speculating and Finance and all that
stuff it's a pillar but it isn't the
organizing principle we see it as one of
the players you know it was the most
advanced we saw the the most important
human capital P lofts already in
2012-2013 II look at the cheese you know
leaving Goldman already to build ledger
X at that time there are you know
Michael Mauro and all these Michael Sun
and shine all these really smart people
already gravitating towards this
industry so they were already getting is
the most advanced they were getting the
most quality participants you of the
human capital flight but it wasn't the
organizing principle when you look at it
you know crypto economics what are they
its economics like we all know it's it's
not a fancy word it's still incentives
it's still choice it's still options
anytime you put the word crypto in front
of something it's just the root word
it's the exact same right crypto
economics crypto securities yep doing
sense yes yeah it's just it's the same
thing exact same input crypto there to
make ourselves feel smart it is well you
know there isn't actually used to it as
far as I can tell and the use is this is
that it's not a subcategory of economics
it's not a derivative economics it's
actually a subcategory of cryptography
and engineering okay that's what's when
is crypto so so the organizing principle
of this a way to do it is to think of
the forces that would shape a
decentralized network how do we harness
these forces to build a system so it's
really about system design and the
economic forces that go into motivating
people to build these systems so that's
what you're measuring you're measuring
the growth of the network you're not
measuring you know so even even pulling
back a bit when coin dust came out the
BPI
which was the reference price of Bitcoin
for a very long time we were the first
to do an indexed price in 2013 it was
about 70 bucks at the time and no one
done it that was great because it was
able to benchmark everyone's incentives
if you backed out
a minor can understand what their cost
was and what their return was so that
was really important but as other assets
joined it kind of took away from that
easy benchmark a bunch of other
speculation came in other networks
Bitcoin was kind of behaving as a
reserve or gold currency of a financial
system not just Bitcoin itself it was
tied into the speculation of everything
else and it became really difficult to
untangle and under to understand where
the growth and value was really
happening we're not gonna be able to do
it out of a simple accounts and it's not
profits and loss and all that stuff so
what are we really measuring here
so we said crypto economics that what's
needed to build one of these
decentralize networks is the the
organizing principle just an organizing
principle so we saw sort of five axes
price still being important exchange
activity being important the actual
network itself being important so that
can be the miners and the merchants
using on chain transactions social media
plays a huge role in this industry
everyone knows the industry lives on on
Twitter and then the developers
themselves like who's showing up to
build these things who's motivated and
then we made one other choice where we
said okay well you know what is 55 trade
pairs for litecoin mean it means nothing
it's abstract so we said well bitcoin is
behaving as the reserve currency of this
industry we can use Bitcoin like water
was used in the metric system you know
we just said water freezes at zero sure
and it boils at 100 sure great then
we'll just divide it evenly between that
what we said is we can understand using
Bitcoin as a ruler we can understand the
size and interest in other networks so
the crypto economic Explorer doesn't
measure the way the way Wall Street
would measure an asset and dollars we're
looking to measure networks and interest
okay price is interesting exchanges are
interested in a coin to list them social
media is interested in a coin in order
to argue about it push it and all that
stuff
merchants should be interested in
various networks and developers who are
giving up their time should be
interested in the platform there they
won't work it so that should be a
motivating factor so we're measuring
interest interest in networks it's
nothing more complicated than that and
so what does this look like in
application right if somebody goes to
use the tool and describe kind of what
that user experience is
and kind of what you were thinking
whatever they get out what that output
is what are they gonna use it for so we
wanted to do was make sure that we can
we can show the level of growth in all
five of these axes right price is easy
that one's already taken care of a lot
of data providers that do exchange some
other ones that do network so the block
explores a few that have begun to
specialize and github stuff and you hear
some social media stuff all around we
combine that all into one platform we
took data sources from all over and then
we also wanted to surface data vis that
would make it easy to consume this
information because you know if the
future is that everyone who's interested
in these networks needs to get a series
7 license and be able to read these huge
Bloomberg terminal terminal spreadsheets
I don't think we've been successful like
and I think I'm the only person who's
anywhere near the finance world who
thinks this the Bloomberg terminal looks
like a casino to me yeah it's like
blinking lights people just sit here at
this casino and you can make money you
can lose money and it has that same sort
of I'm surprised they don't put the
sound on the car do people winning and
gambling I've noticed that intimacy
knows works like the audio you know it's
not even the machines ringing up
victories so yeah it's uh you know it's
neat they show who's you know on the
indexes who's making money and and and
things flash and it's it's it's pretty
funny absolutely so yeah the conclusion
the tool is simple I mean if you come in
you can see the surface area of the
shapes that are drawn so we used a radar
map a pentagon along these five axes and
if a coin you know has a lot of
development and social a lot of
developments in exchange but nothing
happening on developers nothing
happening on the network that you know
that should be an indication that this
this coin needs some serious second
looks and and to find out if anyone's
actually building what you want to see
is something growing along the lines of
Bitcoin we know bitcoin was shaped by
those crypto economic forces it worked
and therefore we can use that to see
what a healthy network looks like so
that's really what the tool is about
it's about showing is it is it grow
in every way because if it grows crooked
a little like a plant you know it's it's
not what you're looking for you're
looking for a robust healthy network on
all these levels yeah it is you know I
think a lot about like Bitcoin is
beautiful and this idea of everything
from the system design to the initial
distribution to the way that people have
described it it's a kind of hit its
stride at multiple points in its
lifetime according to different economic
you know components different nation
states that are doing things and people
have really taken an asset and they've
made it what they need it to be right so
sometimes story values and doesn't
medium exchange sometimes literally just
for speculation right but but I do think
it's one of these assets that we full
you know we really understand yet we
don't understand at all absolutely and I
you know what you're describing in terms
of the growth and a lot of the network
effects and how that interest is very
very different than a majority of what
we've seen kind of launched in the last
two three years yeah yeah and and that's
the way we approached it we said if
we're gonna if we're gonna make a useful
tool for people we can't just do what's
out there already because that mean it's
fine you know who is it was great to
show that these things were real they
were happening people were trading them
that was that sort of psychological
thing that I mentioned earlier it was
very useful to a market cap to
understand that there's people
interested and buying it okay great what
are they interested who else is
interested is it just speculators is it
just people trying to pump a bag on
social or what else is going on here
yeah and so that's really what we're
trying to uncover I speaking of pumping
bags one thing that just fascinates me
is imagine if like the boiler room crowd
right you know from the what is it 90s
or whatever if they had social media
like everything we know that they were
doing now imagine if they had the tools
that we have today it is amazing it is
it's created that tribalism but that's
kind of what these coins need I mean if
there is if we're inventing the future
of these networks there's no room for
sentimentality and that that's one of
the great things that that I think the
the whole Wall Street pillar of the
industry is brought these are not
sentimental people they're not coming
because they want the same things that
the early Bitcoin people wanted for for
a macroeconomic and central bank change
they came because they said okay this is
a new asset people are making money I
want to find out and make money and they
if this thing doesn't work or if they
don't like that community they're able
to call it out really easily and that's
important you know that's the sort of
anti fragility of these networks if
they're not capable of taking criticism
then what's going on here I've often
done that you know I've done a lot of
the event work for coin desk as well to
make sure that the people we have
speaking at our events are top-quality
speaking about really relevant things
and interesting things and I've often
said to the critics that we go out and
get look bitcoins a big kid it can take
whatever you have to say cuz people are
very nervous to come and criticize and
it's we want to hear everything yeah ben
horowitz it talks a lot about like
peacetime CEOs and wartime CEOs right in
this idea that usually somebody is one
or the other right so they're really
really good at running a company when
everything's going well when things you
know [ __ ] the bed day em sale or vice
versa you've got kind of a fixers the
people can come in they can fix problems
and they get really bored when the
company is doing well and the kind of
unicorn or the holy grail of a founder
or somebody who can operate in the
peacetime and wartime and you know as
you kind of think of it most crypto
assets live perpetually in wartime right
there's somebody who's trying to attack
them and somebody's trying to beat them
there's somebody who's always you know
criticizing them whether it's both you
know technically or some of the social
aspects design and and so we've just
never seen this before right where every
single project every single asset in an
entire industry is at war time 24/7 365
on a global basis right and so the ones
that have persisted or thrived like
Bitcoin it's pretty amazing to see that
happen in such a short period of time to
have withstood all of this and that's
really the most important thing I mean
every day that Bitcoin survives it is
more like what gold is supposed to be in
our economy it behaves more and more
like old and that's that's really what
we want to see we want to see it take
all of the
abuse and criticism and of course
there's the joy of getting to throw it
in people's face again because you know
we're pretty convinced that we're right
about this but yeah it's it's a neat
part of the industry and I think keeps
the fires stoked absolutely all right so
you've got this really interesting
theory about aetherium and the ERC 20
standard and how it has shook the world
right talk a little bit more about why
you think that and what that impact
means moving forward well it was a
contract you know this is what I would
often as everything was going crazy in
in 2017 and and we're looking to help
people and guide them and so they don't
just get swept up and everything and
then as things came down they said all
you you know you guys were wrong about
this and that and I said look this was
one contract it was one simple contract
and it shook early-stage finance the
whole world found out about it and and
you know a lot of the pretzels and
mental gymnastics to make them utility
tokens because of the whole regulatory
stuff I think made things come out
pretty crooked and because it was so
novel it really ended up creating a
situation where you know raised time
and so the ERC 20 toking shook
early-stage finance but it mean it's
pretty crazy to think about you know
there's one smart contract one protocol
we're going to call it and not only the
the the real impact right meaning that
look there was billions of dollars put
into companies right global investor
base all the stuff but even bigger than
that was the fear that it drove into so
many different industries right and and
you saw incumbents in finance incumbents
and supply chain right all the way
through you know transportation saying
oh my god this thing is coming right and
it was like the writing was on the wall
and they literally started making
decisions out of fear yummy just
absolutely well I mean they saw the
truth the the way it had worked before
was you you went with your hand out with
a great idea to the VCS and beg them and
and you know it was it was kind of a
cleek they knew who was great and and if
he got an interview one place they
couldn't wait to give you money and if
you didn't then you know if you were on
the outside it was a power pendulum
right so so I always talk about this
thing where the pendulum had swung in
the favor of investors and investors
were able to dictate terms they you know
come you come pitch me while I said on
my throne mhm and what we saw in 16 and
really in 17 was the pendulum swung back
in the favor of founders and there was
no rules
yeah and they could raise money from
anybody and all of a sudden if you sat
on the throne or not didn't matter your
dollar was good right or your aetherium
or decline was good and and you know
like anything that happens at one time
the ambitions were wildly outstripped
what was possible and we had these huge
raises that were probably unnecessary I
mean I don't know how many people need
four billion dollars to build a network
it's you know I hope everything works
out but it had shrunk the distance
between idea and market
more than it has ever been trunk in the
history of the world more than the
internet itself could have done this was
a really remarkable shrinkage of that
distance so that anyone in the world
with a great idea now theoretically have
the opportunity to get that idea
financed of course the whole thing kind
of went sideways right we had a lot of
rent seekers along the way the ability
to sort of launch a token had all kinds
of lawyers and none of the things we
really wanted yeah the things that we
were trying to get rid of so for a brief
period a trunk that distance then all of
a sudden it grew it more so from that
you know you start to say okay well what
were the problems and how can we fix
these we see already with the JOBS Act
in America you know the 1 million dollar
crowd fund rates don't figure the Dow
failed two tests the Dow failed the
Howey test as well as is this an exempt
market offering you know it was a simple
test to determine it wasn't it raised
too much money
so we talked a ton about the Howey test
on the podcast but maybe explain a
little bit about the exempt market so in
the JOBS Act when it came out was really
designed with the idea in mind that
small enterprises would become major
employers and that the ability to launch
a small enterprise and raise money to
get it going
was going to be the driving force so
they created the crowdfunding exemptions
which were pretty simple so they go back
to the 32 33 34 acts you don't need to
be an accredited investor but you can't
invest more than $10,000 a year and the
companies that are raising only need can
only raise a million dollars and it's a
pretty simple process you file and it's
done it's just you know unless they get
back to you and say this is not this is
not compliant otherwise it just let them
know just notice them that you're doing
this and then show them that you didn't
raise too much and and and continue with
your regular filings and a lot of stuff
so they created this vehicle which has
been kind of used here in there this is
it's not really caught fire because the
$1,000,000 raised is pretty low
one of the great things that could
happen that the SEC could do is just to
put a zero on to that raise and I think
a lot of troubles would go away for both
the crypto industry and for the SEC
they're not gonna have to look into
these small projects all the time that
are being maybe clearly you know in
violation of rules and ripping people
off but ten million dollars raised is
not a systemic threat to the economy
you're I mean that's really what the the
acts were all about right those old acts
were really about making sure that the
Great Depression didn't happen again in
the Wall Street Crash of 29 didn't
happen again that's why they put them in
in the first place
you know the the 20s you know people
compared crypto often to the 1990s I
compared to two different eras it's sort
of wider internet revolution which is
kind of like what Niall Ferguson talks
about this is the Reformation it's it's
you know it's the 15 1600s it's nothing
to do with with bananas and the other
one is the 1920s but we saw with the ERC
20 and 2017 was a lot like Wall Street
in the 1920s when it was really new and
exciting and all kinds of projects were
being launched and tons of them more
scams and but everyone was participating
everyone went had their chance at making
money and then when those laws came in
they basically said to you know 90
something percent of the world forget it
you you know don't look here you're too
stupid you'd have no business around
here so that's one of the really neat
things the RC 20 did is it said to the
world again here you go like you can
participate in this you do have the
access to this stuff and so I'm really
keen and excited and and and would love
to see that at zero added to the exempt
market and I think it would be a great
thing for a lot of crypto projects ten
million dollars is enough to get your
thing going for sure do you think there
will be similar shockwaves that go
through at the scale they did from RC 20
with new protocols new standards and can
there be multiple ones that happen in
the future I don't think it's kind of
episodic if you will one at a time so
you know the the the the good news is
some important infrastructure was built
with what happened in 2017 stuff before
for sure so it's not all 2017 stuff
these ideas were around for a while but
there are now opportunities to use
what's already been built to do things
that are
similar to the RC 20 boom so personally
for example I've got a science fiction
book that I've worked on since 2015
Bitcoin themed and and all that stuff
I'm doing a royalty contract you're
launching a coin yeah basically I mean I
don't want it to I'm not keen on it
trading on exchanges that's not a second
market thing yep but the infrastructure
is there for me to do the following I
can offer a contract for 30 percent of
future earnings to investors and it's
just paid out when I sell it for dollars
on Amazon and iTunes and all that stuff
that infrastructure is there to empower
me individually so one can imagine that
while the ERC 20 was really good for
teams to build stuff the stuff that's
already been built can help individuals
use this stuff to help themselves I mean
one of the worst financial contracts
which exists in the world today is the
royalty contract it's abysmal it's
terrible you get nothing if you're a
writer or a musician or an artist but
the infrastructure is there now to do
this in crypto and so there is an
opportunity for that once again that
distance between idea and market to
shrink and and for people to be
individually empowered so that could be
one of the next big booms where people
start using this stuff and start
building on it so I don't want I'm not
building a coin to get transactions off
other writers doing I don't care right
if I do it and I'm successful other
people can copy it and that's that would
be the good news yeah I mean what you're
talking about is an experimentation that
you know some people would be in the
camp of oh this is dumb you know I don't
want to use it so you should never even
try there's a second camp and probably
camp that I'm in where experimentation
of every form should be encouraged
because we don't know right exactly and
so you know I have my personal opinions
about certain tokens or networks or even
you know designs and the people behind
them right but I think that we've got to
as an overall industry get much more
serious about saying I can disagree with
you and still want you to be
experimenting and still trying to figure
things out because there's there's a
nonzero chance that you actually do
figure something out that I can
incorporate into what I'm doing
absolutely and and and that's I guess in
another part of the industry that needs
to be further communicated to the wider
world because at the base we are talking
about cryptography we're talking about
cryptography here coach ography is not
the same as a computer game it's not the
same as just your normal consumer
Internet it works in a very different
environment and and you know if it if it
is like video games right then it would
be you know you have pong which is
Bitcoin is fun right we can move value
from here to there it works perfectly
and it actually works it's a real video
game it does what it's supposed to do
and probably doesn't even need to change
it's perfect and elegant the way it is
right it does its job
pong didn't need to be changed pong is
still a great game there's a bit of the
experience in pong and every single
other game and it is used as this guide
but this you know experimentation side
of crypto because there is an
adversarial environment because it must
we only know it works if it lasts for
years and no adversaries break it it's
not an overnight thing it's not like can
you get to the end of Mario you know
does the game do the animations and
graphics work for you to get to the end
you know if there's a bug in Zelda like
a bomb doesn't blow up well it's no big
deal instead a patch and you're good
encrypt it's not the same
it's either bulletproof or zero there
isn't a middle ground so experimentation
is hard in this industry it really is
and so it must be encouraged because we
need it but there is a conservatism
which is important too
and so you know one aspect that people
probably don't give enough credit to in
crypto is the methodical kind of very
slow intentional safe software
development of Bitcoin for example is to
avoid any issues the contrary to that or
the opposite is that a ton of these
projects were racing right they were
trying to go to like a startup this is
we're racing to get code written and out
into people's hands and iterate right
and we've taught founders to do that
when building companies what you're
describing is actually that mentality of
kind of agile software development
is a detriment when you're trying to
build a store value we're trying to
build a medium video change the Silicon
Valley fail fast and break things does
not work here
it just doesn't it's it would it doesn't
work in very specific use cases yes it
works if you're building you know the
next supply chain what I'm doing it
works for right I mean I'm not
threatening protocol I'm not creating a
protocol I'm not doing the RC 20 by the
way because my book is Bitcoin theme so
I must connect it to Bitcoin so do you
RSK don't ask it yeah so that's not
gonna hurt pick one at all it's me
seeing if I can use Bitcoin to do this
and and I think I can but yeah I mean I
I never really had skin in the game as
far as the big debates for scaling went
for Bitcoin but I will say is that to
see the consumer facing people get into
dialogue with the actual cryptographers
and core devs and then that the outcome
was that prudence and security won the
day I think was really encouraging
really really good news for the industry
because if it had been the other way
around then we don't know what the
answers are right now the important
thing is to preserve Bitcoin and make
sure it keeps being pong keep doing what
it's supposed to do we don't need to
turn pong overnight into a role-playing
game with shooter capacity and none of
that's important like we don't need to
pack coffee today it's not important
it's funny because everything that the
detractors used to negate the importance
of Bitcoin or actually the core
strengths of Bitcoin solutely right and
what it does is it very very quickly
illuminates those who understand it and
those who don't
now we've got a lot of work to do to
help everyone understand it but but it
is pretty funny to me too you know when
you hear people say oh it's slow okay do
you know why it's slow do you understand
the advantage of it being slow and it
goes even more fundamental to that it's
it's it's you know that there's a
conference called RSA okay it's the
largest cryptographers conference in the
world and at the end they have a panel
called the cryptographers and that's
where they have Shamir and all the great
Krypton whitfield diffie they all come
for this last sort of really prestigious
panel session 50,000 people in las vegas
massive massive conference so they had
last year because our crypto had sort of
usurped the word crypto they call their
industry crypto right yep and so that
was the big joke to start all crypto you
know he's not a crypto so they had all
these really smart people right really
smart the pioneers of Riva Shamir the
RSA guys everyone right and they went on
about how oh the hash rates too high why
does anyone need that hash rate they
kind of you know poo-pooed on everything
to do with with with crypto for quite a
while in the one-hour panel and then
they followed it up immediately after
with a talk about Cambridge analytic on
Facebook right and then they sat there
and moaned and cried their eyes out that
their work is not a priority to the
c-suite in their company that privacy
and cryptographer security work is never
gonna be taken seriously by the CEO of
Facebook and missing that and I'm
sitting there really frustrated watching
this the only guy to stand up for crypto
was Whitfield Diffie in the end for our
crypto they're sitting there saying okay
you know bitcoin does all these things
but it's stupid and then why aren't we
taken seriously by CEOs of companies you
know what we're saying is you're
actually in charge in our industry like
you guys now privacy and security are
the premium they're what work we need to
be guided by that's that's the advantage
of the industry and so your ideas are
the selling points your talents and
skills that you bring to make these
networks robust and anti fragile and
secure are exactly our advantage and why
we can win absalom so to see these
people complain about not being taken
seriously while at the same time
cuckooing on crypto made me have a whole
new respect for the cryptographers that
are in our industry who are finally
bosses you know I mean like that but
Zuko is the boss of his company and then
you know the protocol itself is another
story but that there is this person out
there who can say I think this and I
think that and he's focused on privacy
and security first means something else
totally different so I can't say who
told me
and they said it joking but what they
said was the internet allowed the Nerds
to have real revenge I'm like all the
business people but they said crypto
allows the real nerds to actually have
the revenge on on everyone who is
pretending and I think what you're
talking about is very similar here where
it's that you know the difference
between a front-end or an app developer
right their software engineer etc but
the people who are working on deep
cryptography just they're different
right and it's different training is
different kind of ethos is different you
know I think just perspective on the
world well it's it's it's a little bit
like you know it's it's it's different
because it's an unfair fight the-the-the
the software people are just ship
software that people will use if they
like it or not it's like an aesthetic
thing does it look good does it feel
good can we get you digitally addicted
yeah yeah yeah with cryptographers it is
how is the person who's trying to screw
me thinking because if there's one
weakness in what they do it can be
exploited they can have a perfect system
one weakness it's over
so it's an unfair fight in the sense
that the adversary needs to find one
weakness and they can topple the Jenga
whereas the person building the
structure has to think of every possible
one and it's very easy that's why you
hear all the new Bitcoin the better
Bitcoin bla bla bla bla bla
come on you know Bitcoin you run for ten
years and see how it goes
you see if no one the daily attacks
finds a way to get in and and that's an
amazing thing that Bitcoin works is
still almost a miracle it's beautiful
that you could coordinate this elegant
system and that it works you know I
often tell people do you know how much
we pay for security in Bitcoin zero it's
an incentive model and people pay to do
it they paid to do it right and then
they win money and grace it's amazing
yeah beautiful beautiful and amazing
alright before we finish up let's do a
rapid fire which news flash is really
not that rapid knowing no one's ever
done it rapid but
what do you think is your most
controversial thought in crypto like the
one thing that you believe that the
highest degree of other people would
disagree Oh hmm I'm gonna call you out
if you don't say something god I'm
trying I'm trying I'm trying to think of
one thing that it's not Wall Street
first but it's not Wall Street first I'm
not I'm not saying that I'm arguing
against the rehypothecation of or the
financialization a Bitcoin that's not
what I'm saying that things like crypto
kitties are probably more important I
don't know I mean crypto kitties itself
but the idea that people can play and do
things you know I fully imagine a day I
know Bryan Armstrong was talking about
it yesterday with with the reddit going
crypto yeah big old yeah I mean I've
been talking about this for a long time
and and I do believe it'll be a job one
day to like stuff on Twitter and share
it and and all that stuff I mean I
really believe that and and I think
that'll be empowering for a lot of
people and that it eventually we're not
talking about a bunch of people who are
you know sort of slaves to protocols and
any of that stuff but a lot of people
just using this to make their life
better yeah which I don't think it's
controversial it's funny because as your
article that said you know the
government shut down a bunch of these
workers are turning to uber live near me
and et cetera to to get income right and
what you're describing is another type
of activity that creates value right and
if you're able to actually get economic
benefit for that value you're creating
it changes the way that people think
about work well change the way people
think about the output in which they
create and I think it flattens things I
mean the the old expression
time is money is really true but it
hasn't been a neat like if you really
got into the formula you couldn't say
time equals money until now you'd have
to say time equals money plus the
inflation that is targeted by a central
bank plus all the other policies that
add cost on to the money so your time is
not converting equally to money in the
end what is Bitcoin it's time it's a
record of time what happened when at
what time
and here we have this sort of flattening
of time becoming money again and and
that's a really important thing because
the most finite resource we have in the
end is our time so how would we spend it
right if you can spend it in an industry
that pays you for your time that's
that's a great thing
have you ever seen the movie I forget
the name but Justin Timberlake and he's
got the but I remember watching that
movie and first I don't know basically
everyone it's a sci-fi type movie and
everyone walks around with a clock on
their forearm and four you get paid in
time so when you go to work you
basically your time gets extended and if
you ever go to zero you end up dying and
if you want to you know pay a toll take
some time off and time is really the
currency and I remember watching that
and being like whoa
right like we have life so backwards
because it was this huge metaphor right
and when you kind of watched it that way
and it just was so just kind of smack in
the face yeah it does yeah it's it's if
you if you're forced to give up your
time it does feel like that that kind of
oppressive not free environment for sure
what was the most important company in
crypto other than a DCG company hmm most
important company in crypto look I mean
I really believe coin desk plays a vital
role in this industry I don't wanna
it's a GGG company but literally the
first person just ignore the rules I'll
think of another one the most important
I mean I don't look that the the one
that I've actually used I don't know if
it's the most important in the long run
okay but something that I used that I
think articulated what was going on well
two people in the early days with zoppo
that we had this mountain top and that
there were people guarding the Bitcoin
up there somehow made people think that
it was it really got through I always
saw people click when I mentioned that
it's pretty badass it's pretty neat yeah
it's pretty neat you know a lot of those
exchange exchanges you know I love the
the sort of privacy focus that Kraken
has as well I'm a big fan of shape-shift
happy to read the way they had sort of
taken account of their last year and
said let's focus on what we do best and
and I'd look forward to seeing what that
is because I do believe that that Eric
is one of the the smartest and and sees
it comprehensively that's really what
what I would I look for people who can
see it the biggest possible story
because we're not dealing and like I
said this Wall Street thing is great
it's fun and we'll always be there we're
going to eat Mall Street that's going to
happen but it is not the end of the
story it's it's a it's a pass it's it's
a it's a stop along the way
yeah sure thank you only for a while
yeah exactly all right what a what one
regulation would you change or improve
if you could absolutely the the
crowdfunding and I'd put that zero and
go from a million dollars yeah ten
million I think ten million is all
companies need to get going in the space
I don't imagine why you'd need that much
more I mean maybe but for the like the
only way this thing is gonna scale I'm a
big believer that we're gonna live in a
multi token multi chain and that's how
it scales it doesn't scale through just
on chain transaction I think it's scales
through the number of chains and coins
that are there and interoperability
being a major part of how that can help
coordinate all this stuff so if that is
all possible then then you know a lot of
these things are pretty bespoke what
we're trying to do what do these things
do they they authenticate really well
because possession equals identity right
you have the key
you are who you say you are by sheer
virtue of having the key which is that
sort of light touch that we want from
from a point of view of privacy and
security in a completely connected
digital world and then and then that you
can sort of extend that to that the
types of bespoke so it's authentication
and authorization what transaction type
in Bitcoin it's simple just send but we
do want to sort of can and bottle all
kinds of transaction types and that's
when we eat the regulator right when we
can start turning the compliance of a
regulation into an authorization on a
chain
then we've done their job and they can
they can just go back and sit in
Congress only which is the way it should
be in the first place we got to get
everyone who's not in Congress in the
Senate sort of you know turned into some
sort of protocol if we can all right
save everyone money tokenized organize
them just I mean what's the most
important book you've ever read I mean I
always go on I'm a huge Mark Twain fan
and I think if you go to Mark Twain's
you know Mark Twain got a start as a
writer of the gold rush he was out there
sort of immortalizing and mythologizing
some of the early Wild West Gold Rush
people he became a travel writer after
and that's what an invented stand-up
common law stuff so I'd say roughing it
which was his experience in the gold
rush was important for sci-fi I'm a huge
Aldous Huxley fan so brave new world for
sure alright one non crypto question and
then I'll let you ask me a question
you're smiling so you already know
what's coming I don't I'm not gonna ask
about alien pets but what do you think
the probability is that aliens exist
pretty low man you think it's pretty
well explained well we IV amelie
disagree but go ahead look I I hope I
hope so I'm you obviously exist or don't
they do yeah I'm a big sci-fi person and
I don't think it's against us but we
have a pretty long reach out there we
can hear and see a lot
and there are anomalies and weird stuff
that happens but at this point I would
imagine we would get some kind of sign
now now it's possible right yeah I just
haven't I would have to see a bit right
now what what uh we've talked about a
couple people we've talked to a couple
of people about this what about the
Harvard professor who swears that the
thing that entered the solar system was
a spaceship yeah I mean if like he's
what he's like I don't care if you
believe me or not I swear yeah I saw
that yeah I'm open to the idea I'm not
I'm not saying I'm not discredit us of
the idea I just would have to see
something you know see something if they
do exist how do we interact like like
what the most interaction or the first
interaction it's a crypto man it's all
math it's all mad though you can
actually use the so that's what's so
neat about some of the algorithms that
have been found like sha-256 this is a
this is a jewel right this is a this is
a rare piece of math that is able to do
pretty magic things it does the same it
produces the same characters eat the
same number of characters each time you
know because these are little
mathematical jewels that you find in in
in the rough they become easy to use to
let's say reverse-engineer communication
and and so in that way they're great we
would we would probably use Bitcoin and
say look we did this it's probably a
step of evolution in every culture in
every world right to come up with a
Bitcoin I'm blown away right now that we
would communicate with them with math I
did not expect you to go there that's
the only way if you take math you can
you couldn't sort of abstract language
not far after and you can use it to sort
of reverse-engineer how we would
communicate so I'm not sure exactly how
but you know some really smart people
could figure that out hopefully they
come in one plus one equals two all
right what a one question do you have
for me hmm
let's come up with one you're way
smarter than me which scares me that
you're gonna ask me something no no I'm
not trying to come up with something
interesting and fun is make it a twitter
centric question of course the crypto
has to be a crypto related no where
would your business be without Twitter
oh it's good question
I have no clue so on the investing side
I've never thought about Twitter
specifically helping sourcing deals
investing etc and only recently probably
last like six months have founders like
started verbalizing this idea of oh man
if you're an investor like you can you
know go and you can basically drive
awareness you can drive acquisition you
can do all the stuff and it's
interesting to think about one of the
things that I've spent a lot of time on
over the censuses I started looking at
this is so do the asset management
businesses today I mean they're really
antiquated right and there's all kinds
of people who are doing some interesting
things you know everyone from like
O'Shaughnessy Asset Management right
well Jim and Patrick are doing - guys
like co-venture and they've got some you
know really unique things but the one
thing that I don't see a lot of people
going after it's this idea of how does
the asset management business change if
you have huge distribution channels
right and that's been a huge
participation base that didn't exist
before exactly and so I don't know what
the answer to that is yet know where
this is kind of like a live experiment
frankly but but we definitely see some
some pretty interesting things and I'll
tell you one anecdote that uh absolutely
blew my mind I won't say who it is but I
walked into a University endowment with
with my partners mark usko and mark
comes from the endowment world he's a
legend in that I'm a whole space and
then we walked in everyone created um
and then the CEO walked in CIO is
probably I'd guess like early 40s and he
walks right over me goes what's up pump
and I was like what how do you know who
I am right why did you just use that
nickname whatever and he's like I listen
to the podcast read Bobo whatever and
and it was really fascinating for
somebody that I never met who you know I
think of as something that I could learn
from and all stuff to already know so
much about the way that we think the way
that we're approaching things things
that we've done when we walk in the door
right and so I think that you know those
aspects are off is a very positive and
hopeful
the there's a downside though right like
you know we make an investment and it
goes to zero not in venture it's not a
big deal like we expect a lot of the
investments we do to go to zero well
when you get thrown to the Twitter
trolls right maybe don't hold it over
your head right yeah you invested this
company you know it went to zero and so
you've got to kind of detach the the
benefits from the the negative side and
a lot of us just managing the psychology
of you know I'm probably not so worried
about the anonymous person on Twitter
who's you know there's one who literally
has the name troll in their name kind of
know why they're right no but I've
watched it from a distance and I think
what you guys have done is pretty neat
for that very reason exactly what you
said that it you know this isn't it is
an antiquated base we saw downtown Josh
Brown do a lot of stuff but this is
still a little different like he's
awesome he's great I mean we love you
know he's always been a big help to coin
desk and has come to our events and and
I think he's a really smart and an
interesting person you know play you
know what I'm gonna call him out right
now he recorded with us before Josh I
hope you're listening to this this guy
told me he believes in ghosts more than
aliens I'll never forget I've seen those
ghosts because something I saw one the
other day that got me too I saw the you
know those those personal cameras are
catching people's ghosts all the time